okay good afternoon I'm Saul silverstein
and today I'm going to take dr. rock and
yellows place hopefully with the same
energy and fervor that he has but I'm
going to talk to you about things that I
know about because I don't know anything
about what he's talked about so far and
I won't pretend but I will answer your
questions today's lecture is about DNA
replication in viruses and the various
families of viruses that dr. raccoon
yellow has introduced you to if you
can't hear me move up I can't speak any
louder and my voice is just going to get
lower as the lecture goes on so let me
warn you when you talk about DNA
replication the major problem that a
virus genome faces is initiation of DNA
synthesis and that's why it's all about
getting started it's how the various
virus genomes use what they have what
they bring into the cell what they steal
from the host after all they are
parasites and how they use that material
to initiate DNA synthesis so you've been
introduced to these various life forms
as I call them and they're probably not
really alive yet but these are schematic
representations of some of the virus
genomes that we've been introduced to on
the top you see the parvo viruses and
they're a family of single-stranded DNA
viruses that are present as both plus
and minus strands don't think of them in
the RNA sense these are plus and minus
in a DNA sense they don't encode that is
they can't be translated directly into
messenger RNA
they must be transcribed first and for
that to occur they must become
double-stranded DNA molecules these DNA
virus genomes are represented by this
very unusual Panhandle structure at both
ends of the molecule and that occurs
because they contain terminal repeats
and inverted terminal repeats I will get
into that in a lot more detail later on
and I just want you to get a flavor for
what we're talking about we'll also be
talking about very large
one very large viral genome the herpes
virus genome and in particular we will
be discussing herpes simplex virus
because it's perhaps the best studied of
the family members and it has a very
unusual genomic structure and we'll
address that a little bit later but the
thing that is of interest most in terms
of what we're talking about is the
presence of three different origins for
DNA replication and they are used under
different circumstances we'll also talk
about the linear double-stranded
adenovirus genome and it's of interest
because it has a v prime terminal
protein that stuck at both ends of the
virus genome and in endless detail we
will discuss replication of this
circular molecule so why do viruses
undergo DNA replication I think the
answer or the immediate answer is pretty
obvious they have to replicate these
genomes to make new progeny everything
is about getting the progeny out it's
certainly true and everything about life
and this almost always requires an
expression of at least one virus protein
that means that the virus genome must be
transcribed at some point in some
instances many virus proteins are
elaborated DNA however is always
synthesized in the 5 prime to 3 prime
direction and it's done in a semi
conservative replication fashion both
strands are replicated replication
initiates that a defined origin using a
primer and the amazing thing is that
these primers can be very variable they
can be DNA structures they can be
Okazaki fragments those small RNA pieces
that are made by prime aces and
polymerase alpha or they can be proteins
and we will discuss examples of each of
those but most of all remembering that
this is a parasite it's the host that
provides other proteins that facilitate
and allow for this very complex and
exquisite replication machinery to work
when to function in cells
now as I've shown you and as you've
heard from dr. Eck janello tee gnomes
come in a wide assortment of shapes and
sizes they're just like people there are
many different flavors replication
yields progeny and replication is also a
very important point in the life cycle
of a virus because it acts as a switch
for gene regulation there are almost
invariably a family of genes that are
transcribed and translated prior to DNA
replication and those depending upon how
they're utilized are called either
immediate early or early genes and they
among other things encode for proteins
or functions that allow for the virus to
replicate its DNA so that's a very
important regulatory event and it
separates the machinery that's used to
activate genes and to activate
replication generally speaking from
machinery that's used to make capsid
proteins proteins that are required in
large abundance to encapsulate and
enclose the various virus genomes it's
always delayed after infection it's
never the first event with one exception
because there's always an exception so
what are the outcomes of DNA replication
usually we think of lytic infection as
being one type of infection and there
it's quite simple
quiet so we get new progeny and lots of
little hairier viruses genomes and we
get high copy number sometimes thousands
and hundreds of thousands of genomes are
made in an infected cell the other type
of infection which is in some ways much
more interesting is the latent infection
and that's when a virus enters the cell
and we'll talk about this in a lot more
detail later in the course and sort of
hangs out it finds a stable environment
a niche where it can be very very happy
where it can maintain its chromosome at
a low copy number and stable e in
assimilation with the host and in some
cases such as the epstein-barr virus it
replicates with a host and it has an
entirely different replication cycle in
latency versus lytic infection come in
these virus genomes can be episome oh
that is their extra chromosomal like
plasmids are in bacteria or they can be
integrated into the host these pose
different problems for when a virus is
reactivated and that occurs in almost
every instance of latency so viruses go
from being from latent Lee infecting
cells to entering the lytic infectious
stage and producing a new project the
triggers for those are some of the most
interesting questions that we ask in
virology now what are the requirements
for DNA replication you require a
specific origin that is recognized by
either host or virus or virus plussed
host proteins for initiation of DNA
replication when the sequence is DNA
it's almost invariably an 80 rich
sequence and it's an 80 rich sequence
because 80 base pairs are preferentially
or more easily opened melted apart by
HeLa cases and that allows
access of polymerases and initiation
factors and proteins be it as they may
to this segment of DNA to begin Copic
priming can result from RNA in which
case you have those small RNA DNA
hybrids that are termed Okazaki
fragments of about a hundred and forty
nucleotides from DNA hairpin structures
with the DNA bends back on itself
exposes a free three prime hydroxyl and
allows for progressive synthesis of DNA
molecules or it can be protein that's
covalently attached to the five prime
end and allows for the initiation of DNA
synthesis the next event is pretty easy
its elongation and while there are
different virus proteins that help
elongation and we'll talk about those in
a bit by and large is the polymerase
chugging through the molecule making its
way through hairpins making its way
through DNA structures melting things as
it goes and there are a lot of ways in
which it can do that at a fairly
constant rate and finally there's the
end or termination and termination could
be a very specific event or it can be a
random event that is random in terms of
the fact that there are no specific
nucleotide sequence that is recognized
by a polymerase or polymerase complex
but yet to replication forks meeting at
ones point and we'll see that when we
talk about replication of circular
molecules okay
other requirements viruses don't
replicate well in quiescent cells
neurons terminally different
differentiated cells really aren't
dividing and because they're not
dividing they're missing a good portion
of the equipment of the machinery that a
virus needs to replicate so for example
a neuron has no ability to replicate DNA
can repair DNA
and as a result of that it's going to be
deficient in certain DNA polymerases
certain kinase Asst ligases all of the
enzymes that are really important for
DNA replication so what does the virus
to do it's clever it induces host
replication enzymes and it induces cell
cycle regulators these proteins are
important for initiating DNA synthesis
so for the host now that doesn't
necessarily mean that the host goes on
and replicates its own DNA in fact in
many cases infection with a virus a
brocades host DNA replication but
because the virus comes in and brings
these handy little proteins of its own
or because they are translated in at
very early times post infection they
induced host replication act enzymes and
this results in activation of the
cellular DNA synthesis machinery
machinery is localized with the
exception of the poxviruses to the
nucleus so you take a cell that's
quiescent is not actively synthesizing
DNA and if you activate the cell
machinery you now provide landmarks and
points within the cell for which a virus
can dock its DNA dock its genome and
initiate the replication process and
indeed these a very limited number of
sites in which a virus
excuse me genome can do this and then
again we get to the point that the virus
must elaborate immediate early and early
gene products before it can begin
initiation of DNA synthesis so what's
the host for the host is a bag it's a
bag of enzymes it's a bag of structural
elements and these enzymes the
structural sites mostly present in the
nucleus provide a place for the virus to
lodge simple viruses conserve genetic
information so they usually elaborate a
protein or two at most and they use the
host
in that case the virus can replicate
along with the host the host will have
some limited DNA replication and the
virus will also have DNA replication
with the more complex viruses however
they encode many but not all the
proteins that are required for
replication so we can put virus proteins
into a test tube along with either a
plasmid that contains a viral or
engineered DNA replication or a viral
genome and get some replication it's
very difficult to get initiation it's
not precise and the reason for that is
that we don't know all of the components
and we don't have the structural motifs
that are required for assembling the
genome in the proper place within the
cell but what we can do is we can add
back virus gene products to cells and
allow the cell to have only a limited
number of virus gene products and ask if
those proteins plus an authentic origin
will allow for replication and we'll end
the lecture on that note so where does
the replication polymerase come from as
I said to you before small DNA viruses
do not encode an entire genome
replication system but they do encode
proteins that are castrate the host so
members of the papilloma veer add a the
Palio move every day and the parvo very
day all small DNA viruses double strand
circles double strand circles single
strand they use a lot of the host
machinery and they tend to encode one to
two proteins to proteins for papilloma
one protein for the Palio material a to
proteins from the parvo virus says
although they're really just as one is a
subset of the other large DNA viruses
encode most of their own replication
systems so the herpes viruses the add no
viruses and the pucks Faraday all have
polymerases HeLa cases topoisomerases
primates as you name it they got it and
here they are DNA polymerase
accessory proteins among them are
primates the primates is important for
initiating DNA replication things that I
may refer to as Oh bps for origin
binding proteins specific proteins that
recognize a site up for initiation HeLa
cases to open up the DNA to melt it to
allow that first set of nucleotides in
action new glace is to pair things back
and repair and other proteins such as
thymidine kinase is ribonucleotide
reductase asaji UTP aces to make
precursors for nucleotides so a
quiescent cell doesn't elaborate these
enzymes so you can't have TTP you can't
make DNA if you don't have authority and
triphosphate so these guys will bring
things in or they'll convert nucleotides
that are present in cells from
ribonucleotides to deoxyribonucleotides
and this helps to get the machinery in
order for the virus to replicate DNA now
that was that's so good okay replication
occurs where did replication centers of
course and these replication centers are
present in the nucleus so what you're
looking at in this panel and this panel
is the nucleus of a cell stained for its
DNA so DNA templates and replication
proteins associate at discrete sites
other than the nucleus that are called
nd tens for nuclear domain tens why
because they're about on average ten of
these inside the nucleus of a cell and
what happens is virus genomes assemble
at these nd tens and it's here that they
initiate DNA replication and
transcription as well the sites are
preferentially used so there might be
ten of them but they're not all equal
and we don't know what controls access
that can all be occupied but replication
occurs at different with the different
affinity a difference
now in this panel is a antibody that's
staining for a particular virus protein
it happens to be a protein from herpes
simplex virus which is a single-stranded
DNA binding protein in the cell without
virus in it of course there is none and
then the cell that has virus you see
that the protein assembles where DNA
assembles and if you were to use this
probe as a probe for viral DNA you would
note that that's where the viral DNA is
and when you merge these two images you
see that they overlap so the DNA
templates and proteins that are
important for replication of the DNA
genome are present in these nuclear
domain tens okay in order to get started
the virus needs to find a place to start
so what's the starting line for a virus
frequently it's these 80 rich DNA
sequences and they are recognized by
avaya as a viral origin by specific
proteins such as arjun binding proteins
these proteins are sequence specific
it's not a structure that they're seeing
but rather a sequence there are
instances of structural dependent
initiation but they work through a
different mechanism and what they do is
they see the Assembly of a multi protein
complex so somebody comes in recognizes
the site and that protein has a surface
that's exposed it's engaged with DNA
once it engages DNA it changes its shape
as a result of that engagement and that
exposed site allows for interaction with
other proteins and what you do is you
build up a multi protein complex and you
can then initiate from that some viruses
have one origin others have up to three
and as I said before they're used for
different purposes
one thing that is become very clear is
that these origins of replication are
often associated
with highly transcribed control regions
and that feature is important because
what it tells you is that these areas
are very active areas so they're naked
areas that are available for proteins to
assemble on them so they're not highly
chromatin eyes in the instances where
the virus forms a chromatin like
template and there are viruses that
don't have nucleus ohms or nucleus
features of nucleosomes but have a
chromatin eyes like genome that his
areas are covered by histones and and
various accessory proteins so we're back
to our or our genomes and once again
we're going to start here with the parvo
Verde we're not gonna actually start
with that and the initiation site for
the Parma Verde is right here or here
depending upon whether this is a plus or
a minus guy for the simplex it can be in
these origin s sequences which are a
complicated portion of the virus
chromosome or down here and a latent Lea
infected cell in the adenovirus it
starts with a protein that which sits
opposite the 3 prime end and binds and
allows for polymerization through and in
the Palio material in the circular
molecule and finding that is difficult
because the molecule doesn't really look
like this but rather it looks like this
this molecule that is just twists it up
on itself and if you introduce a Knick
anywheres in this highly super twisted
molecule then you'll open it up and
you'll get what's called a relaxed
circle so the highly super coiled
molecule is form one and the relaxed
form is formed two
how many of you can see the rubber bands
would it be better with the lights on
maybe Oh Carrie
if you take a rubber band and you pinch
off the top then it remains just the way
you see it deserve it as replication
proceeds though the top gets pushed out
DNA gets extruded through a machine
we'll talk about that in some detail and
behind it because this part is unwound
behind it it tends to curl up like that
it gets all knotted on itself and that's
a super coil and the only way to release
that is with an enzyme called the
topoisomerase which puts a Knick in DNA
and unravels it like that so those are
some of the real problems that are
associated with DNA replication and
we'll try and address them as well so
here's your super coiled DNA molecule it
starts as a circle and what happens is
it gets all twisted up on itself and the
more twists that are introduced the more
compact the molecule becomes until it's
a very thick of it as a as a as a ball
of string almost it's a very tight
coiled subject a whoops a single Knick
in that molecule however by tope isomers
will push it all the way back to this
relaxed form open closed compact spread
out so what is an origin look like well
not exactly like this but somewhat like
that and what you have here is a
schematic representation of a family
book I don't have the stamp prior of a
family of origins from different virus
genomes sv40 is a member of the Popova
virus family and what it has is this a
tea rich sequence here and another one
here and what you see is something
called LT binding site one and binding
site ooh LT stands for large T antigen
it's the immediate early or early gene
product of this virus it's the only
protein for all intensive purposes
that's made right after in
affection and entry into the nucleus so
it's transcribed before DNA is
replicated and that protein is required
to initiate DNA synthesis and what
happens is T comes back and it binds
right at this site which is adjacent to
the early promoter and it helps to open
up that sequence and make it available
for DNA replication herpes simplex virus
has an origin that's a little bit more
complicated it's a very very large
palindromic sequence and it is very 8e
rich and it's a tea rich in the context
of the virus the virus is about 68% g
plus c and this region here is 40% so
that's very a tea rich and that's
recognized by its origin binding protein
and much like sv40 the origin is placed
between two transcriptional units again
allowing access and for adenovirus we
have an entirely different picture we
have it's double-stranded genome the
five prime end of it has something
called terminal protein 3 time free 3
prime end is accessible and what happens
is it recognizes TP and puts on a
molecule which we'll talk about later
and that's how it initiates its
replication so what are the various
recognition proteins how do they
function paloma T antigen binds
specifically to DNA it is a site
specific DNA binding protein
papillomaviruses used to proteins II one
which has helicase activity and is
absolutely important for origin
recognition but doesn't bind
specifically what it requires is another
protein elaborated by the virus called e
2 e 2 binds to a specific sequence in
Popova virus DNA and allows a one to
come in and then you can start
initiation so it's a two pronged attack
noe two comes in first because e one is
just just spaced out alright it doesn't
know where it's going but once it has e
two available it can find where it needs
to be the parvo viruses have a protein
rep 68 and 78 and I said to you before
that there are two proteins and what
they are is one is a subset of another
but what they do is also bind at the
ends of the single-stranded DNA and the
double standard molecule and they unwind
the DNA allowing for access it's
interesting because this protein is also
involved in terminal resolution Analects
you don't know what that is well we'll
explain that as we go forward the
terminal protein in adenovirus begins as
a pre terminal protein PTP and that
binds a determinist and it recruits DNA
polymerase and then DNA polymerase has a
very specific function for adenovirus
and that is to place a deoxy site any
moiety onto a serine of PTP and that
site adine is actually the primer for
DNA replication initiation of DNA
synthesis herpes viruses use a protein
uo9 and that's an origin binding protein
again site specific and it recruits a
bunch of viral proteins 280 rich origins
and that unwinds DNA so just to give you
a little more feel for where we're going
again we're going to come back to our
genomes and you remember that we have
double stranded DNA it can be
transcribed into mRNA and it can be
replicated into double-stranded DNA and
go into the particle the polyomavirus
genomes are circular and super coiled so
they're all twisted up on themselves we
have here at adenovirus genome the very
large herpes virus genome and the pox
faraday which we're not going to talk
about because that would require an
entire lecture to even begin to explain
them but they're actually just a big
circle all right they're double stranded
and the ends or cove well
we closed okay so that's the
double-stranded guys what about the
single-stranded guys the single strand
guys are generally speaking pretty easy
to understand you either get a plus
strand and it gets made into a double
strand which subsequently can be single
or double stranded and packaged or you
have this guy the circle Verde which dr.
raphaela mentioned which is a single
stranded genome in only one
configuration so if you think about it
it has to use the host the question is
how is DNA synthesis primed what's the
origin for DNA replication and that's an
unknown and this is of some interest
because it turns up in all sorts of
different products so for example there
were a large a large batch of purified
protein that's used to treat I don't
remember which disease and was found to
be contaminated with circa virus DNA or
virus particles and so all that stuff is
thrown at millions of dollars worth of
product the question is why we have no
idea what this virus does it doesn't
seem to have caused any pathogenesis
where did it come from probably from
from some serum component that was used
to grow the cells but without knowing
what it is there's a reasonable doubt
and so you get rid of it and we have a
parvo vera die which started
single-stranded molecules get replicated
to make a double-stranded DNA molecule
and keep doing this back and forth and
we'll we'll show you what that's all
about in a bit the last one and we're
not going to talk much about it but this
is hepatitis B which is thankfully
pretty much under control because of
good vaccination protocols but this is a
very interesting molecule because you'll
note that it's sort of double stranded
and one strand is complete and one
strand is incomplete
and the incomplete strand actually
overlaps the other strand so what you
have is a five point men that has to be
cut because this guy's going to
replicate further so the first thing
this virus does where this virus DNA
does when it gets into itself but if you
used the host to repair this molecule
and then it becomes a super coiled
circular covalently closed DNA molecule
then it can be transcribed and begin its
process but the most interesting fact is
that after it does all that it's really
a retrovirus so you'll learn more about
that as we go through the retrovirus
lifecycle so there are two basic modes
of replication there is replication fork
based synthesis where there is a leading
strand where DNA replication elongation
is continuous starts at a specific with
a specific primer and just reads through
and there's a lagging strand and the
lagging strand is initiated with RNA
molecules and it is done discontinuously
in viruses such as papilloma virus
polyomavirus herpes viruses and even the
retrovirus is at least in the pro viral
form use that mechanism add no viruses
and parvovirus --is and poxviruses with
their hairpin use a strand displacement
mechanism that is they displace one
strand as they replicate another here's
your parental strand here's your other
parental strand this one gets displaced
as new DNA is laid down then the other
one gets replicated and we'll go through
that for adenovirus okay let's start on
a replication journey with polyomavirus
replication forks as i said to you
before initiation is from a single
origin single site sequence specific
recognition by the T protein T actually
stands for tumor antigen and it's
because part of it gets elaborated on
the surface of cells that are
transformed by this virus and that's an
early protein it's the first
first protein made in the infected cell
these molecules replicate as covalently
closed circles that is they remain
circular during the course of
replication and that goes back to the
rubber band
part of that circular molecule is
actually extruded and is relaxed and as
hell and the extruded part is held in
place sort of like when you ride a horse
in your gallop and you hold your two
hands together with the reins
I'll show you about that in a bit
leading strand replication occurs by
extension from an RNA primer and the
lagging strand replication can't start
until the replication fork has moved
some until that leading strand fork has
moved it also uses RNA primers but it
creates discontinuities because it's
replicating in the same direction and
the only way it can do that is by
essentially replicating backwards and so
you're left with a conundrum of how do
you fill in the gaps so to talk about
polyomavirus replication you need to
know something about the properties of T
antigen and you'll also know need to
know something about these properties
when we talk about transcription because
this is a very diverse molecule that
provides for a great number of functions
during polyomavirus replication as I
said it's a DNA binding protein perhaps
the most fascinating feature is that
it's species-specific so a polyomavirus
that's originates from a mouse cannot
replicate in human cells and vice versa
and the reason for that is that pre
initiation complex is do not form in the
wrong species so if you have a human
virus you put it into a mouse cell it
gets into the cell it finds nucleus and
it does squat it just can't do anything
because it can't initiate DNA
replication and the reason for that is
it doesn't interact with the host DNA
polymerase alpha prime is protein
complex so it can't initiate
this protein binds and sequester's
cell-cycle regulators why because it
causes cells to enter the S phase so why
is that important for these viruses
because once they enter s they
synthesize DNA or they gear up the
machinery that's used to synthesize DNA
so it becomes available its synthesis is
auto regulated that means it turns off
its own synthesis it makes a large
amount then it shuts itself down the
protein is heavily modified that means
it's decorated with other moieties such
as phosphates and ribosomes and a and
addenda scenes and things like that and
it's the decoration that controls its
ability to bind DNA and the various
levels of decoration also control the
cooperativity of the molecule that is
the molecule actually forms hexamers so
there are six t molecules in each active
replication fork complex and it is this
cooperativity and protein modification
that affect unwinding of DNA opening up
the helix and the best work on this has
been done actually by Carol Provost here
in the biology department and so here's
TD T antigen as a schematic it's a large
protein 708 amino acids and it has all
of these various binding all of these
various protein domains that are
important for interaction for example
with polymerase alpha of the host p53 a
cell cycle regulator it has an ATPase
activity it has single-stranded DNA
binding activity
it's a helicase that opens up DNA it
binds to the origin of DNA and it
interacts with proteins such as the
retinoblastoma protein another important
cell cycle regulator and cell heat shock
proteins which are important for how
proteins fold and what they interact
with so this is an enormous ly
complicated molecule it has many
different sites that are phosphorylated
and it's these sites of phosphorylation
and other modifications
that control how and what the molecule
is doing at different stages in virus
replication okay we're back to the core
sequence and this is where the virus
initiate its DNA replication this origin
is between the promoter for the early
region and their promoter for the late
region and that's because this is an
area that opens up and is
nucleosome-free and its nucleus home
free so that there's accessibility this
super coiled DNA molecule is covered
with histones and it looks for all the
world just like a normal chromosome so
it's totally wrapped up around
nucleosomes there were a bunch of
binding sites that are adjacent to this
core or within it and they're the sites
for binding of T antigen and also for
transcription activation and it's a
t-wrench so we've laid out the circular
molecule as a linear form with its
single origin and what I can tell you is
that replication is bi-directional
so it's proceeding in both directions at
once starts at the single site goes
around the chromosome in two directions
as a result of that you have two
replication forks we're going this way
and one going that way and the origin
has now been duplicated and you have
what are called leading and lagging
strands with the two replication forks
what's the difference DNA synthesis on a
leading strand is continuous it doesn't
have to stop for anybody DNA synthesis
on the lagging strand is discontinuous
it's a series of short new poly
nucleotide sequences that are primed by
RNA extended in the same manner that
leading strand synthesis is but because
it's going backwards it runs out of room
and we'll see how that works
and then you have a problem of putting
those pieces together so what happens
when you initiate here's our origin of
DNA synthesis and here is our hexameric
large T subunits and they bind ATP once
they assemble on the chromosome as I
said before do you think of it as two
fists and they're right next to each
other what they do is they distort that
palindromic sequence which is present in
the core and begin to unwind the DNA and
that's what's represented here and what
happens is that DNA gets extruded it's
now a single strand one in one direction
one in the other because remember we
have two replication forks and excuse me
a host protein called RPA or replication
protein a now assembles on the
single-stranded DNA so it's a single
stranded binding protein and this in the
presence of a topoisomerase remember
that topo everything's wound up so
that'll Nick and allow things to unwind
now allows for the extrusion of the DNA
and makes it available as a template for
DNA replication so you now have the
origin exposed and it's available now
how do we know there's a single site for
DNA initiation this is a great
experiment this is one of those you know
pictures a thousand-word guys and
okay and it's nice to think about if you
assume that a circular molecule has a
single site of initiation and that
there's also in a symmetrically position
restriction endonuclease site then when
you open up the molecule the origin of
DNA replication will be a symmetrically
positioned from the ends and that's
shown down here look at that little
bubble as the origin and you can see
that its distance from the origin to the
left end versus the right end is quite
distinct again here it's better shown
here that's the origin that little
bubble and this is one arm that would be
this long one and this is the other arm
and that would be the short one okay now
as DNA synthesis occurs and as DNA along
gates this bubble gets bigger gets
bigger this DNA is replicating and
eventually it begins to expand until it
occupies the entire sequence up to the
restriction site once you pass the
restriction site it gets cut and you
have two of them molecules that are
dangling off so now how do you know that
replication is bi-directional anyone
don't all shout out what tells you that
it's bi-directional yes
all right the ends are getting shorter
it's growing in both directions at once
yes well watch the distance from the
bubble to this end gets shorter as a
replication proceeds until you get to
the point where it's really close and
once you get to that edge so what you
have to remember is that this is a
molecule caught in the act of
replicating it's not like a bandit right
and then you cleave it now if that
cleave if that site the restriction
enzyme site whereas replicated so where
the green dot is now here those ends
would now be open because they'd have
been duplicated okay
so back to replication all right we now
know that it's bi-directional we know
that it starts at a unique origin and
now we have the problem of leading and
lagging strands that is remember DNA
only occurs DNA synthesis only occurs in
one direction 5 prime to 3 prime so if
you start with your leading strand and
you replicate here continuously how do
you replicate this part of the
replication fork and that's the issue
well you do it using Okazaki fragments
Okazaki fragments as I said before are
RNA prime DNA poly nucleotides so what
happens is once this leading strand
begins synthesized it begins to be
synthesized then the polymer ASIS and
we'll go into this in negging detail in
a second now have available to them
parts of this replication fork using
polymerase alpha as a Primus and T
antigen is sitting right here and here
by the way you now lay down a small
track of ribonucleotides which have
three prime ends that serve as primers
for initiation of DNA synthesis so the
DNA synthesis starts here and goes to
there and then it starts again further
upstream
you can only go there because you've
already synthesized that piece
the problem then becomes putting these
guys together and they're put together
because remember there's an rna-dna part
and what happens is the RNAs are removed
by specific X nucleus DNA is repaired
and who ligated and filled back in so
the leading strand is easy a preset
assist complex between polymerase alpha
one of the host DNA polymerases T
antigen and replication factor a forms
on the template replication factors C
binds the product of polymer ace alpha
at the three prime hydroxyl along with a
protein called proliferating cell
nuclear antigen and this is a clamp that
is it's a ring structure that sits on
the replicating DNA molecule and in
order for that clamp to get on to the
DNA it requires replication factors C so
C is called a clamp loading protein it
actually allows access of PCNA and
polymerase Delta and polymerase Delta is
the guy that's responsible for extending
the DNA chains
so once PCNA is on DNA it releases
polymerase alpha and polymerase Delta
can do its business RFC and PC and a
form sliding clamps along the DNA and
then you get continuous copying of the
parental strand don't worry I'm going to
show you what that is the lagging strand
is not so easy
the first primers and Okazaki fragments
are made by polymerase alpha primaries
complex then the DNA is copied from the
replication fork back towards the origin
that's why I said it's going backwards
it's going in the right direction but
it's starting further on up the Turnpike
multiple initiations are required to
replicate the template strand although
unlike the leading strand the lagging
strand requires many many starts both
leading and lagging strands move in the
same direction and then the question
becomes which moves the DNA or the
complex
and it turns out that the template has
to move otherwise you can't unwind this
mess
so the actual complex with t-antigen
isn't where the replication forks are or
held a stable configuration so how do we
know things unwind at the origin well
when you look at them when you catch
these molecules in the act
these are t-antigen hexamers 1 2 and the
DNA gets looped out it's single strand
and we know it's single strand because
this has been visualized with the aid of
a protein that recognizes single
stranded DNA a single stranded binding
protein so it only binds to the signal
stranded area of the molecule so the
part that's not in the process or being
prepared for replication finds very
little of the protein because it's
double stranded okay what are the host
factors proteins that are required can
you see this I'm just going to elaborate
them we'll go through them quickly
replication passionately it binds the
single-stranded DNA Argent unwinding and
cooperation with large t DNA polymerase
alpha primates that's required for
synthesis of RNA primers the beginning
of the Okazaki fragments and it's used
on both the leading and lagging strand
RFC is a atp-dependent clamp loading
protein and it's also required for it
not only engaging PCNA but releasing it
from DNA PCNA is the sliding clamp it's
the structure that allows the flow rates
to get to it and polymerase Delta is the
enzyme that provides her process of
synthesis of both strands when bound to
PCNA so this is the DNA polymerase and
then we have another couple of
characters in here there's RNA SH which
removes the RNA and the RNA DNA hybrid
so that part of the Okazaki fragment
which is RNA and then there's a protein
fen one which is a 5 prime to 3 prime
exonuclease which also is involved in
removing RNA primers and finally DNA
ligase there
more proteins but enough is enough okay
so this simple diagram shows you how DNA
replication is bi-directional and it's
really not that hard so I've broken it
up into two parts and the first is the
leading strand and let's just follow
because all I'm doing is recapitulating
what we've spoken about for the last ten
minutes it gets easy you look at the
pictures they're pretty that's it's cool
alright so we have two large T hexamers
and they've extruded DNA DNA is
single-stranded and bound by RP a
polymerase alpha prime ace this little
guy here the glue the olive green and
purple guy comes in on the leading
strand recognizes the origin along with
the oxy nucleotide triphosphates and
ntps because you need ntps to make
whatever nucleotides it synthesizes this
rna-dna hybrid once that first Okazaki
fragment is made RC binds the three
prime end of the RNA DNA hybrid okay
because you've got one strand that has a
little bit of RNA in it and a little bit
of DNA so the three point of that is
bound and PCNA is added on in the
presence of ATP so now we have this
structure which is the loaded clamp once
that occurs polymerase alpha which
started the whole thing is knocked off
and polymerase Delta comes in and in the
presence of deoxyribonucleotide
triphosphates it synthesizes new DNA so
now we're making double-stranded DNA in
this direction and in this direction
that's the leading strand and the
leading strand is elongated now once
this opens up then it frees the lagging
strand or it makes the lagging strand
accessible to the same family of
proteins polymerase alpha and they can
put in their RNA initiation nucleotides
so you get your rna-dna hybrid molecule
and it starts there and it's running in
the same direction and of course it runs
out of room because it's already double
stranded on the leading strand so
start here you go to the origin origin
to stop and you start here you go back
to where this was made and you stop and
you start here and you continue in that
process so it's really an ungainly way
to do something because it's a constant
series of stops and starts but it's the
way you make the other part the other
part of the molecule and this yes no
this is all going on at the same time
the only thing is a little bit of a lag
in getting the lagging strand started
which is originally what I was called
lagging we didn't originally we did
first we didn't know that it was
discontinuous we weren't smart enough to
figure that out and then a series of
host enzymes come in RNA say chief n1
and ligase to complete this double
stranded molecule so you end up with
removing the RNA filling the gaps and
sealing it and if you look at it at the
replication fork it looks like this
here's your tea antigen hexamer here's
the parental DNA
right this is what you start with
there's a little motor in there a
helicase which opens everything up
separates the strands and makes them
available for DNA synthesis one is
continuous that's leading strand and one
is discontinuous where small loops of
DNA are pushed out and they get
replicated and then the next loop comes
along and gets pushed out and they get
finished in that way to show you what
see can I start this from here okay
can you hear that if not let's kill it
what's important here is to realize that
here's the parental strand coming in it
gets unwind by this for your blue
molecule and it pushes off a leading
strand where DNA is made continuously
and the lagging strand where it loops
out the DNA is a template allows for
formation of that Okazaki fragment fills
that thing in and then adds it back to
the molecule that's being replicated
whoops didn't mean to do that
okay now you're left with the problem
you've made DNA you have a circular
molecule and if you make DNA from a
circular molecule what do you get anyone
you get another circular molecule right
so you have two circles and the problem
with these two circles is that they're
actually intertwine so you have to
separate daughter molecules from the
replication complex and that's where
enzymes such as topoisomerases come in
they relax these super coiled molecules
and they unwind them and what that does
is relieves torsional stress in the
molecules and permits them to come apart
yes it only cuts one strand at a time so
it holds it intact it has a way of
cutting and then cutting and even when
it cuts two strands are there top ones
and teleporters in these different guys
they hold the molecule together because
if they didn't hold the molecule
together you'd never get that circle
back okay so and in fact that's a more
complicated issue which I didn't want to
get into but that's your answer you're
left with two molecules that are
intertwined and those are called cata
nate's molecules that are wound up
inside of each other and you have to
separate them out and that's what the
topo to does it Cleaves and reseals
through hydrolysis of 80p so what does
that look like as you look at
replication here's your replication fork
and remember the top of the rubberband
top of the rubberband was just hanging
there like a rubber bed just like the
rubberband you always knew and loved the
bottom part got all tangled up because
when you released the energy here and
you allowed it to unwind it transferred
the energy down through the rest of the
molecule and caused it to twist up on
itself so that part was overwhelmed and
those are called super coils and
eventually you end up with something
that looks like this except this is all
twisted up and as this grows it gets
bigger and bigger strand one and strand
two think of them as thing one and thing
two from
practices and you get this molecule
which is a cat Nate it's two circular
molecules that are wound up inside of
each other and they're actually super
coiled and what the topoisomerase does
in all of its glory is separate the two
molecules so you get a blue blue
molecule and a red molecule of course
they are the same how else can you prime
DNA synthesis you can prime it using a
specialized structure and a specialized
structure in the case of parvo viruses
is itself so itself primes forms a
template primer the genomes of parvo
viruses are both plus and minus strand
and they contain inverted terminal
repeats and as a result of that he is
the end of the molecule the
three-pointed of the molecule
there is a sequence within a hundred
base pairs of the end that's identical
but the exact inverse so it's
complementary that allows the formation
of this hairpin and has happened has
this very lovely three prime hydroxyl
which is a great place to start
if you have something to copy and what
have you got to copy you can copy
yourself that can make some dirty jokes
about it but I won't so this virus is
called a depend overs because it depends
on the host in order to replicate it
doesn't use the polymerase alpha because
it doesn't need the RNA primer instead
it uses its inverted terminal repeats as
the primer for DNA synthesis but it uses
all the other friends that we talked
about polymerase Delta RFC and PCA it
also needs 78 and 68 proteins that are
elaborated shortly after infection and
they form they provide two functions one
is the initiation of DNA synthesis the
other is resolution that is getting
those single strands back out providing
new templates so they have endonuclease
activity a helicase activity to unwind
and they bind the five prime terminus of
the genome there is no replication fork
in this guy but we're gonna have
semiconservative replication why because
we have plus and minus strands and we'll
show you how that happens so here's a
parvo virus DNA molecule single strand
and it has not only those inverted
terminal repeats all right but it also
has these larger inverted terminal
repeats so the three prime end and the
five prime end are the same except
they're backwards back there compliments
of one another they could form a
structure like this where the one that
we've been showing you all along where
the ends hairpin out and form this
structure when you have this structure
you have a natural template for DNA
synthesis so the molecule could being
elongated blue is parental red is de
novo synthesized when this molecule
forms rep 78-68 recognizes this sequence
and it Cleaves it now look what you've
got you've got the rep protein sitting
at the end of the molecule okay at the
five prime end of the molecule and the
molecule is part new and part old
something borrowed something blue okay
so what we have here is a hybrid
molecule parental and daughter and the
end of the parental strand once this is
Nick it's released extended out this end
can be filled and now you have two
strands each of which is a hybrid
molecule that is part new part hold but
if you look very carefully what you
notice is that the sequence at the ends
which went from a b c ad is now a CB ad
and it's a function of this having
folded over on itself and what happens
is each time you replicate it you get an
iteration of it and you get a change
when this protein binds when 78-68 binds
it allows for displacement of this
strand and this guy can now fold back
over on its
as did before and you can continue
synthesis again so each one of the
hybrid molecules part parental part
daughter strand are capable of being
replicated and they replicate exactly in
the same way and you get thousands and
thousands of genomes in the cell
single-stranded and both plus and minus
strands are packaged so that's pretty
cool
another way of initiating DNA synthesis
is through protein printing priming and
the adenovirus uses that and it uses
that precursor to terminal protein that
I alluded to before
PTP and AD no DNA polymerase so ad no
encodes its own DNA polymerase and
before it can replicate DNA it has to
make PTP and polymerase it also makes a
bunch of other proteins but we won't get
into those today
aDNA polymerase links the alpha
phosphoryl of dcmp to a hydroxide of a
serine in PTP it's only added that is
this dcmp is only added when the protein
primer is assembled with polymerase into
the pre-initiation complex at the origin
so it doesn't just get randomly added to
the protein it's only happens when that
protein is recognized DNA that allows
for the three prime hydroxyl to act as a
primer for the synthesis of the daughter
strand so that tells you immediately
that the other strand has to end in a g
because it's got to be complementary and
then you get semiconservative DNA
replication from different replication
forks we'll show you how that works so
here's our adenovirus genome 3 prime end
of the template strand is your 5 5 5 to
3 prime three prime to 5 prime 5 prime
end is bound by terminal protein why
you'll see in a second what happens is
the three prime strand recognizes this
complex invades along with add no
polymerase and then once it's seated the
polymerase places
the deoxy sighting moiety onto the
serine of PTP another virus early
protein that's made is called the DNA
binding protein and that's a single
strand DNA binding protein it's made an
enormous amounts and what happens is
that as this molecule extends DNA the
other Strait gets pushed out and that
single strand gets coated with DNA
binding protein so that's the displaced
single strand template this guy finishes
its replication so now you have
semiconservative replication right
daughter parent and strand that is
displaced is now covered with DNA
binding protein the ends anneal the
three prime end is recognized by PT P
and DNA polymerase and it starts the
whole cycle over again and it replicates
the other strand so what you have is
discontinuous semiconservative
replication so it's strand displacement
synthesis adenovirus uses a protein
primer as a pros to a DNA primer or an
RNA primer there are origins at both
ends why because this molecule sits down
when it recognizes a 3 prime end and any
linear molecule has to three prime ends
any duplex linear molecule has to three
prime ends you get the Assembly of the
pre terminal protein into a pre
initiation complex that activates the
polymerase two covalently linked the cmp
two the serine residue in PTP and then
you get semiconservative DNA replication
from different replication forks now
life is not always that simple sometimes
it's even more complicated and viruses
of the herpes virus family or most of
them have multiple origins of DNA
replication and herpes simplex virus has
two identical origins that are located
in a portion
of the virus genome known as us for it
known as the S sequence for short so
there's a short and a long sequence and
what I will tell you and you don't have
to you're not responsible for this but
you should think about it because it's a
mind bender is the fact that the
junction between these sequences short
and long acts as a molecular swivel and
so you can get molecules that have long
running this way and short running this
way long running this way and short
running this way the inversion of short
inversion of long and inversion of both
so there are four different forms that
are present in any population of virus
molecules and they were equal molar we
don't know why we're not even really
sure how they occur there are lots of
theories about them most of them are
just that they're conjecture but the DNA
does enter is a linear molecule from the
virion and shortly after it enters the
nucleus it's converted to a circle and
circles are sometimes good things
because they're pretty easy to replicate
the virus dissociates host nuclear
debate ends and re-enters whatever that
spaces that was filled with nd tends to
form replication factors with both host
and virus constituents and it replicates
as something that's called a rolling
circle so what does that look like that
looks like this
here's your circular molecule there's a
Nick one string gets pushed off the
other straight gets replicated and the
Strand that gets pushed off is your 5
prime n right here now it gets
replicated in this direction so what
happens is the circle rolls and it rolls
off these long lengths of genomic DNA
and these are also catenate so those of
you know something about lambda DNA
replication know that it replicates as
catenate admonishes
and these have to get cleaved at very
specific places and they get packaged so
that's a continuous molecular machine
that is rolling out long loops of linear
DNA in order to do that you need a
variety of herpes simplex virus gene
there are three that form a primates so
these are three different gene products
that are required to form the primus
activity there's another that's a
process 70 figure protein and that helps
the DNA polymerase move through the
viral DNA we talked about you online at
the beginning of the lecture and that's
its origin recognition protein the one
that sees the origin UL 29 is the DNA
binding protein for herpes simplex virus
and finally we have DNA polymerase and
you isolate all of these proteins and
you get the chemically pure and you
throw them into a test tube along with
an appropriate origin of replication and
you get nothing so it tells you that
their nests well it doesn't tell you
that they're necessary but not
sufficient but it tells you that they
alone are not enough to replicate viral
DNA so what has been done is each one of
these gene products has been obtained
from or has been cloned the DNA that
encodes it has been cloned and those
clones have been transformed into
mammalian cells along with a plasmid
that has an origin of replication and
DNA that's made in plasmids is cleaved
by an enzyme called DPN one which only
recognizes methylated ad names and
mammalian cells don't have methylated ad
means they only methylated site of him
and so if DNA replicates then this
plasmid molecule this is a southern blot
after cleavage with DPN will no longer
be cleaved so this plasmid sequence will
be copied and you'll make thousands of
copies of it but only the original
plasmid sequence from eco I will be
cleaved so here it is thrown into a cell
with any one of those seven gene
products left out with any one of those
seven genes left out you get no
replication if you have all of them in
the mixture that is a mixture of cloned
fragments plus template then you see
replication so this is termed DPN one
resistant
and that's how we know that these guys
are important for replication we just
don't know all of the host components
that are also important